in this video I'll be talking about
pentose phosphate pathway pentose
phosphate pathway is one of the most
important biochemical pathway in our
body because it generates reducing
equivalent which is NADPH and that can
be used for several reductive
biosynthesis pathways like fatty acid
biosynthesis
but before understanding the Pindos
phosphate pathway we should ask three
questions where does it occur when does
it occur and how does it offer so the
context is super-important so let's just
try to understand the context of pentose
phosphate pathway and its necessity in
our body so our body is like a mega
factory so it has our own production
house own warehouse and from there its
products are delivered into the
marketplace or the places where there is
demand so our body has also energy
demand and the energy in order to cope
up with the energy demand
there are several biochemical pathway
which crosstalk between each other in a
context dependent manner to fill our
body with energy and that that's what
keep us going and this biochemical
pathways are actually categorized under
simplistic chemical reactions like oxido
reduction reactions condensation
reactions transfer reactions
isomerization reactions etc and all
these things takes place inside our body
in an enzyme dependent manner right now
among all these reaction schemes one of
the interesting and important reaction
scheme is oxygen reduction type reaction
and in this situation somebody is losing
electron and getting up see the oxidized
and somebody's gaining electron and
getting reduced so inside our body the
reduction reaction requires enzymes and
second of all major reducing in reducing
equivalent which gives electron
basically what needs a electron donor
the most popular and most important
electron donor inside our body is
basically NADPH now NADPH can donate its
electron and thereby the substances
could get produced and this we would
look in details in which biochemical
pathway there is usage of NADPH
but for now on lettuce I try to
understand that NADPH is required in the
body so body should has a production
scheme by which it can produce nadph in
a consistent manner whenever there is
necessity of NADPH it can generate so
generally NADPH is required for fatty
acid biosynthesis detoxification of
xenobiotics raus production and also
docks to combat oxidative stress so in
our body there should be a steady scheme
a steady biochemical pathway by which
NADPH can be produced and that
biochemical pathway is nothing but
pentose phosphate pathway right now so
key importance of pentose phosphate
pathway it can give rise to NADPH which
can be used in several context and
second important aspect is it can give
rise to nucleotides and it can help in
nucleotide by synthetic pathway because
in our cell in order to produce energy
or various other aspects list let's say
for cell division you need nucleotides
because new DNA or new RNA need to be
synthesized so the nucleotides has the
sugar part and the sugar part is
provided by the ribose 5-phosphate in
the pentose phosphate pathway so in that
context Windows phosphate pathway is
also important for nucleotide
biosynthesis now we would look at
Windows fast pathway in very not much
details but in an overview so the key
aspect of pentose phosphate pathway
starts with glucose 6-phosphate
glucose 6-phosphate gets converted into
several intermediates some of them are
six possible goukan eight and rye
Baloo's 5 phosphate and ultimately it
produce ribose 5-phosphate and in this
process of generating intermediates in
an enzyme dependent manner they produce
nadph so the nad p is getting reduced to
NADPH and the NADPH is then going to be
used as reducing agent
and the ribose 5-phosphate would be then
used for nucleotide biosynthesis now you
need to understand that this in order to
give rise to reducing product in a
consistent manner or producing
nucleotide bias in a nucleotide in a
consistent manner this part we need to
go on and on and on so there is should
be a recycle mechanism so the recycle
mechanism is from revolutionize
phosphate to glucose 6-phosphate and it
can regenerate glucose 6-phosphate which
could be further channeled into the
pentose phosphate pathway to generate
the following products so clearly there
are two phases one is oxidative phase
which would give rise to the necessary
product and there is a reductive phase
the reductive phase we can understand as
a recycling phase like by which we can
it can generate the raw material and can
use up the raw material again so we
talked about the oxidative phase first
because this is the important phase and
reductive phase definitely it is
important but not so important in a
conceptual manner so the main raw
material for the oxidative phase is
glucose 6-phosphate now the glucose
6-phosphate would be first converted to
six phosphoglucose
telt a lactone which is a intermediate
by lucas 6 phosphate dehydrogenase as
the name suggests the enzyme is the
hydrogens the hydrogenation is almost
equivalent to oxidation right so this
glucose 6-phosphate is getting oxidized
and something in parallel has to get
reduced right and the thing that is
getting reduced is nothing but nad p
which is keep getting reduced to NADPH
now this energy pH which is produced in
this oxidative phase of Pinto specific
pathway can be used in several other
biochemical pathways you can see in
phosphor Gookin adele's a lactone there
is keto group whereas in the glucose
6-phosphate there is alcohol group right
so there is a alcohol to ketone
oxidation and there would be further
oxidation steps by which 6-4 glucan or
Delta lactone is converted into six
fossil unit by the
actress and further with another set of
dehydrogenase enzymes which is six
phosphor gluconate dehydrogenase
ribulose 5-phosphate is produced now
again there is a dehydrogenation
reaction that means something is getting
oxidized and you can clearly see at this
step another NADPH would be produced
which would be important reduction
equivalent so something has to be
oxidized at the same time and co2 is
released in this process because it's
also a decarboxylation step down
reaction and here again the alcohol
group is oxidized to a ketone group and
now we understand that oxidative phase
how in a series in a serial manner the
NADPH is produced now after that isomer
is the enzyme convert ribulose to ribose
5-phosphate now this ribose 5-phosphate
can enter and give rise to nucleotides
and it contributes to the sugar moiety
of the nucleotides now after that the we
talked about that how NADPH could be
used to combat Ross the NADPH which is
produced in the Pinder's phosphate
pathway so these are reactant of
oxidative oxygen species which could
cause harm in our body so body need to
counter the reactive oxygen species and
in order to counter reactive oxygen
species body converts reactive oxygen
species to less harmful species by the
enzyme glutathione peroxidase and this
bruticon peroxidase need to be need
glutathione and the glutathione need to
be reduced in a cycle different cyclic
manner otherwise the gsh peroxidase
enzyme won't work so oxidized
glutathione need to be reduced and
definitely the reduction reaction needs
NADPH as an electron donor
so definitely gsh reductase which is an
enzyme in an NADPH dependent manner it
would reduce
glutathione so where does this NADPH
come from this NADPH is actually
obtained from Pentos
phosphate pathway so wherever our body
is facing so much of oxidative stress or
anything then pentose phosphate pathway
is getting up regulated and pentose
phosphate pathway is generating a hell
lot of NADPH which could be used by the
raw scavenging machinery and whereby our
body could get protection right let's
talk about fatty acid biosynthesis
pathway in the fatty acid biosynthesis
pathway there are several metabolic
steps where NADPH is used as a reducing
equivalent to reduce something right now
and the NADPH comes from pentose
phosphate pathway so we can understand
that's in this metabolic pathway fatty
acid biosynthesis the pentose phosphate
pathway derived NADPH is so important so
without in any pH this is reductive /
synthesis pathway won't occur we talked
about another important component like
cholesterol cholesterol synthesis takes
place from HMG way in the endoplasmic
reticulum membrane the key enzyme the
rate limiting step is HMG query
DuckTales reducing HMG quai into methyl
on it and Mabel on it gets converted to
cholesterol in a series of reactions so
this is the key rate limiting step and
again hmd query ductus is an inductors
enzyme so it also needs a reductant
reduction equivalent which is obtained
from NADPH and the energy pH is produced
from pentose phosphate pathway so in
multiple different biosynthetic pathways
and protection protecting our body
against cross NADPH we just arrived from
pentose phosphate pathway is
super-important now till now if we have
talked about the oxidative phase a
little bit but not about the reductive
phase now if you remember we talked that
reductive field is a recycling phase so
you recycle the glucose 6-phosphate nkn
such that you can channel it into the
pathway and produce more energy pH or
generate nucleotides right so this whole
process is bit complicated and requires
several metabolic intermediates and
these metabolic intermediates can be
also
to other biochemical pathways so the
ribose 5-phosphate get converted to
cedar Abdullah's 5 phosphate and
fructose 6-phosphate is generated from
that and fructose and glucose are pretty
much similar both 6 carbon they could be
converted to glucose 6-phosphate via
isomerization reaction these steps are
actually catalyzed by trans aldolase and
trans catalyst so basically these steps
are with aldol condensation in a
chemical point of view and the last tip
is isomerization in alternative fashion
there could be production of his i'll
you loose 5 phosphate from the ribose
5-phosphate and there are a series of
metabolic intermediates which would
ultimately lead to production of glucose
6-phosphate so the metabolic
intermediates that i talked about are
not so important but what is important
is from ribose 5-phosphate they they can
recycle that and channel that into
glucose 6-phosphate again such that this
whole process worked like a cycle and it
can generate NADPH as a reduction if we
power it right and that is how the
oxidative phase is a key production
phase and the reductive phase is the key
recycling phase and that is how this
scheme of NADPH production goes on
inside our body and it fuels our body
with a lot of reducing equal balance and
also protects our body by augmenting dra
cross scavenging mechanisms and now the
concept comes is glucose 6-phosphate
which is the ingredient which can be
both used in like Oasis or in pentose
phosphate pathway so when does body
choose to channel the glucose
6-phosphate in look like on this pathway
or when does it prefer to put it in a
pentose phosphate pathway it all depends
upon demand and context let's say now
body is undergoing a fasted state so
body needs energy so in that situation
glucose 6-phosphate would be converted
to pyruvate and in this process of
glycolysis but it would generate some
energy and it would provide the body
with energy but let's say now we are in
a fate state and in this situation but I
don't need any more energy right now
because there is already energy exists
and now what I need to synthesize
multiple different substances like
cholesterol like fatty acids etc
etcetera so body need reducing
equivalents in that situation pentose
phosphate pathway would be preferred and
glucose 6-phosphate would be channeled
into pentose phosphate pathway instead
of collisions so how the metabolic
substances or metabolic intermediate
would be used inside our body it always
depends upon that demand and the context
so I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked the video give a thumbs up and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you